we got this one from the Wall Street
Journal rep ilhan Omar ousted from
foreign affairs committee by GOP and uh
you know I don't really care they
removed her I agree with Matt Gates when
he said removing her from her committee
simply because you don't like what she
said is kind of stupid but I think he
voted to ouster right he voted in line
with the Republicans is that what it was
I think I saw that everyone did yeah all
the Republicans were in favor and and I
think what he said was this is different
this is not just removing Schiff or
swallow from a committee this is putting
up to a vote and then you know the vote
of course succeeded but here's what I
want you to see
you guys ready to listen to this no
Democrats scream no
is on adoption of the resolution those
in favor say
aye
those in favor say no
[Applause]
opinion of
make it louder Play It Again keep keep
going yes they're still going and
without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table
those in favor say yay those in favor
say nay like and she's supposed to say
those against say no not those in favor
say yay those in favor say no Tim I
think you got to play it again yeah I
think you got to Play It Again
those in favor say no
oh yeah those against say no ladies so
wait wait basically she tricked them
yeah so everyone yeah unanimous removal
of villain it depends on the text of the
motion
[Applause]
is on adoption of the resolution those
in favor say
aye
those in favor say no foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
conduct himself with dignity Lauren
bobert and Marge Taylor green heckling
during whatever so right these are bad
like I'm sorry are you not up holding
yourself to the same conduct that you
apparently expected there's one more
isn't there uh I don't I don't have the
Corey Bush one pulled up no the AOC
you've got you got to have the AOC I
hope I hope that my friend Alex Stein
hasn't seen this it might put him in the
hospital when he sees the AOC video
today but let me address something very
quickly right here because this is
called retaliation
the right here we didn't start this and
I I'd like to write Fusion this is
retribution retribution and retaliation
we were putting points on the board and
this is something where if you saw
Jordan Peterson has this whole thing now
about oh we need to be careful that uh
you know the left doesn't use this kind
of I'm sorry have you seen the left
lately have you seen what they're doing
have you seen what they're doing to
Children guess what we we're going in
and we're going to use whatever tactics
necessary to correct the problem and if
there is a tactic that's already been
used against people on the right like
Marjorie Taylor green like they tried to
do it but I don't even care I don't even
care who it is I don't care what they
said I don't care what they did we're
going to use it back tenfold until it
stops I get well do you think it'll make
it I don't know if it'll make it stop
though because it's like saying okay
nobody can hit anybody then the kid hits
the other kid and you're like oh and
then the kid's like I want to hit him
well in some situations you're like you
know what yeah hit them back then no no
you got hit you could hit him back and
then no more hitting until the entire
system is corrected and this is the
difference between the new right and the
old right the old right will sit there
and and plain about oh but we're you
know we're you know how dare we use
those drop boxes we shouldn't use drop
boxes at all and the new right would be
like I want dropboxes in the back of
every Church in the country yeah we had
a Rex Santorum on and he's like we can't
impeach Joe Biden we don't do that we're
better and I'm just like them than you
lose you know
Rick Santorum was my first boss in
politics and uh nothing but respect for
rjs nothing but respect for the senator
nothing but respect for uh for what he
did and by the way being one of the
first people to say things like it takes
a family to raise a child not a village
not a socialist system
um but I do think yes at some point you
got to take the gloves off yeah yeah
yeah
um if you want to keep losing I get it I
can respect the attempt at honor and
integrity but uh look man we're just at
this point where
you know as I was mentioning with Hassan
you know that segment I I did a response
to him like a half an hour long because
Ian pulls up this video the other day
where he it's like Hassan calls out or
Tim pool calls him I was like I was
defending him but the point is there is
everyone up again if you literally can't
even agree with these people and they'll
come after you or deride you or insult
you then there's no point in trying
anymore and you're not going to win
anything by just giving people who are
crying what they want and in this regard
you take a look at what we have the AOC
video I'll play this one you look at
what happened when Marjorie Taylor green
and ghosts are get removed they're like
this is an injustice well you'll see
what happens they literally cry it's
it's just like that Meme where the where
the feminist is throwing manure over the
wall into the internet yeah and says
opinions and then people throw it back
she goes help misogyny it's like dude
here you go you guys ready for AOC wait
wait wait wait wait wait always wait
hold no no no all right there we go a
general woman is recognized for one
minute let's go thank you now
as also as a fellow New Yorker I think
one of the things that we should talk
about here is also one of the disgusting
legacies after 9 11. targeting and
racism
Americans throughout the United States
of America and this is an extension of
that Legacy consistency there is nothing
assistant with the Republican party's
continued attack except for the racism
and incitement of violence against women
of color in this body I had a member of
the Republicans here we go
and the Republicans rewarded him with
one of them
no she's so she's she's saying that
claiming the ghost anime video ghost are
posted Attack on Titans which showed her
as a gigantic human eating monster being
uh slain by Warriors it was a threat on
her life it was distasteful in my
opinion like I understand the humor
behind it but I'm like I don't know if
it's appropriate you want to you know
put that kind of thing when people took
memes of the remember the first Kingsman
movie yeah and you remember I'm not
going to describe it because we're on
YouTube this isn't the third hour right
right but you remember the the church
scene yeah and they took like uh Colin
Firth is like kills everybody different
different you know I'm just gonna say
political opponents and attach them to
that it's a I I wouldn't post something
like that yeah it's like a will you read
it
she hung out with gosar during the
McCarthy vote and you could see the
pictures of her like oh everyone being
like what is this it's performing very
into him while she's sitting that
picture by the way is
some interesting right now she knows
she's being filmed and she's campaigning
Congress don't tell
me this is about consistency oh yeah oh
yeah
Marjory Taylor green literally never
said that this is insane she did say in
a Facebook post could lasers have
started these fires and then she made
one reference to funding from a bank and
then the media was like but that bank
was owned by Jewish people therefore
she's talking about Jewish people and
now AOC goes on the floor of the house
and says Jewish space lasers an entire
amount a tropes and also elevated her to
some of the highest committee
assignments in this body this is about
targeting women of color in the in the
United States of America
yes
these people are evil I love the spice I
love it no I love her I love it I'm
sorry this is your thing yeah right
she hits the table when when she is
performing to manipulate the public to
gain power that to me is what evil is I
mean there's other forms of it don't get
me wrong you know like killing people
and stuff like that but I'm saying this
is malevolent you're saying what she's
doing to the people who are receptive
and like we're laughing about it we're
being we're being jovial but you can hit
the quote tweet button on Twitter right
now I'm sure and you will find people
that are absolutely lapping this up yeah
and they're crying it's like I'm
breaking my heartbreak for this country
thank you AOC thank you for speaking up
these are the same people who believed
her when she implied and you know what
I'm going to bring up she implied that
she was in the Capitol on January 6 and
that people were coming to kill him no
no no no she made that story up in its
entirety AOC said in a live stream that
someone was pounding on her door and she
went and hid in the bathroom and then
heard where is Shane that's right where
is she the only problem first every
conservative comes out and says hey wait
a minute she wasn't in the Capitol
building and everyone in media
Huffington Post they came out and said
yes but they're connected and she was
scared that they made it through the
tunnels and I had a dude from having to
post reach out to me and say hey you're
wrong about your Tweet you need to take
it down AOC those buildings are
connected and then I responded with I
talked to him I was like oh wow I didn't
realize so I took the Tweet down and I
was like my bad I'll show correction
I checked the timeline and then I said
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait and I
messaged The Huffington Post guy back
and said yes the times frame she
mentioned in this story no one breached
the building until an hour afterwards
and he was like no that that must be a
mistake then he got back to me goes oh
you're actually right yep AOC lied that
whole story is a lie what really
happened was the police were evacuating
the building if AOC knew and it was an
hour in advance that people were going
to storm the building why didn't you
tell anybody because either she knew in
advance before anyone breached the
building that they were going to that it
was going to happen
or she's fabricating the story was this
before the okay so when you look at the
timeline and of course you know shout
out to revolver news and darm Beauty on
this
we know that the timing of when Ray Epps
first hit those barricades was almost
precisely coincidental right precisely
coincided with when the pipe bombs were
reported outside of the DNC and the RNC
almost like someone was trying to divert
resources away from that initial and by
the way when I say the initial
barricades these are hundreds of feet
away from the steps of the capital
itself these are all this is what you
would consider part of the lawn right
the National Mall but so when that point
had this knock on the door happened yet
did she know about the pipe bombs or did
this even precede that I don't know if
she knew I don't know what she knew but
the event the reason this some the cop
knocked on her door was that they were
evacuating because of the pipe bombs and
that was a full hour before the capital
was actually breached so AOC had no
reason to believe now what she's doing
is in my opinion using hindsight now
that she knows it happened she's using
that image in people's minds to say how
scared was I when they were coming in
the building right but think about at
the time not a single person knew the
capital would be breached so her story
makes no sense it's a fabrication she is
a liar she is malevolent she is an evil
person sometimes victims of trauma
misremember you know it was literally it
wasn't even 24 hours later she told this
story yeah but she just remember it was
like a few hours later she's like here's
what happened but you know like when a
victim in the park gets jumped by a dude
and she's telling the story of the cop
she's like yeah he was wearing a black
jacket with a they're like do you know
what color his hat was
it wasn't 10 o'clock uh it was a sign
out um the sun was out why was the Sun
out at 10 p.m uh I made the story yeah
that's why there are examples of like
victims talking bro experiments this is
why you can't take witness testimony as
fact well okay AOC goes on her Instagram
and lies like she always does stop
defending but whether what you eating
whether or not she was being malicious I
don't think this is that that situation
I don't think there's that situation at
all I feel like your yours is closer to
like if someone got jumped and the first
thing they did was go to the media
Instead This is why this is why victims
don't serve on juries by the way you you
cannot claim that AOC who was evacuated
specifically because of a bomb threat
and that's what they were told then
accidentally conflated that she thought
before the before the breaching the
capital that the capital had been
breached they went to the tunnels made
their way to her office and then tried
breaking into her room that's insane
well they say the capital I think the
cap Capital grounds had been breached if
bombs had been placed but that's what
I'm talking about is when they're
decided they're using the most expansive
definition you could think of in terms
of capital grounds and these are
normally uh public areas this is why and
I was there on January 6 covering it for
oan
that this is why a lot of those people
who are walking around on the grass
didn't think they were doing anything
wrong because that's on any other day
you're just allowed to walk around there
right this is not the steps doors this
wasn't anything like that and so uh
where and re-ups and those guys who were
maskless by the way cutting down
barricades while President Trump was
already was still talking uh those guys
never identified never charged and they
set up the entire thing and many of the
people who walked onto the grounds into
the building were behind where the
barricades were breached so imagine
you're you're a bumbling Goddard with a
bunch of people walking around confused
there's no barricades it's a straight
path up to a door and the police opened
the door and say don't agree with it but
I respect it and you're like I wonder
what this I wonder what that's about
yeah that was that was on one side of
the building on the other side you had
people fighting don't get me wrong those
people should be locked up I remember a
lot of those people didn't even know
that there were barricades in the first
place I remember Standing On Top of 101
Constitution Ave and I said that exactly
same thing as it was happening I said
the people it because on Constitution
Avenue it's it's it you're all the way
back you have no clue what's going on at
the front so you're just walking up and
it's you're just following the crowd at
that point and one-on-one Constitution
Believe It or Not of course same uh
address where the pen Biden Center is
where they found the classified
documents
um so I'm standing on the roof of that
saying these people are going to walk in
and they're going to get blamed for this
and they're going to have no clue what
transpired before because already cell
phone service was down signal was down
you had no clue you had no way to be
able to find out what had happened and
so even when
they made all these arguments about
Trump's tweets etc etc how would you
know right there was no way to get
access well Twitter or anything like
that we talked to uh like well they call
him Podium guy but it was a lectern
right and he said that he had no idea
like his his phone's basically dead and
off and he's walking around confused
like I don't know what's going on then
he leaves and all of a sudden he's like
all over the news and they're posting
these pictures of him yeah he had no
idea what's happening and they tried to
make it seem like he was stealing it
when he actually said he moved it like
20 feet put it down and then did like a
you know yelled something and then
walked away it's like somebody else had
moved in he was moving it back no no he
saw it under the stairs or something and
then picked it up and put in the middle
of the room and then like said like haha
like he was giving a speech and then
just walked away wow oh they made and
they made it seem like he was stealing
it from somewhere thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time